coach our flight to Mexico City doesn't  leave for another 10 hours hey you got  to be prepared for everything  [Music]  let's practice is Spanish I made you all  learn City barbecue in Mexico you know I  hope it's cool to add like 20 carrier  I'm detecting a lot of weapons we have  to potentially explosive offenses better  hurry Jose gonna have a game script for  this somewhere I have the perfect play  Oh God they're both so innovative hey  man we're the same we're both  frontrunners ha I am very clearly  affordable oh we made it  hell yeah let's go come on Travis can  the play defense always an afterthought  [Music]  subscribe his channel watch my puzzles  I gotta go